hey guys it's max today i will be doing
a multi-tasking
ram stress test comparing an eight
gigabyte m1 macbook pro
to a 16 gigabyte version now yesterday
vadim did an excellent video
looking at the performance of
professional applications a gig
versus 16 gigs of ram but a lot of you
guys wanted a multi-tasking test
to see how well these macbook pros
perform when you have a bunch of tabs
open
multiple creative applications do we get
any slowdown stutters
and along with that what happens with
your swap files
and your ssd so we'll be talking about
ssd longevity if you should worry about
that if you have an eight gigabyte
version
and ultimately which one you should buy
and if it's worth spending the extra
money
now i have both models right here i have
the 8 gig on the right
the 16 gig on the left other than that
every single thing is
identical i know some of you guys asked
for macbook airs
unfortunately those are sold out for the
16 gig version or else i would buy one
but the macbook air performs almost
identical to these macbook pros it's
incredible so i would just look at this
test
now i am going to download chrome which
was just released for apple silicon at
least the first
version and right here you see mac with
apple chip let's download that
i just restarted both macs just to be
safe and i have
one chrome tab open we're going to run
this as our baseline performance test
for web browsing
and i just have my isat menus open i
also have creative cloud open like i
typically
would and let's open up the activity
monitor here
and if we take a look at ram used our 8
gig model has 5.5 gigs used
plus some cache a little bit compressed
and then the 16 gig model has seven gig
used and actually more
cash so there's space ready for
extra usage so let's go ahead and grab
our baseline performance test in chrome
here we go we have 209 and 212
basically identical and i have to say
that this performance is very impressive
before the arm optimized chrome 1000
around 100
and then safari is about 225
so chrome now as far as the performance
is getting very close
to safari now opening a few tabs in
safari because that's how i typically
use it
i'll have some things open there so i
can separate it from google chrome
where i do most of my work and now
getting back into chrome i'm gonna open
up some more tabs i'll open up youtube
and play
a 1080p youtube video and then open up
my channel dashboard
then a couple different emails and then
google drive which always seems to kind
of lag
because i have so much stuff in there
and i think that uses a lot of ram
let's go ahead and scroll through my
google drive i don't know if it's just
the arm version of chrome
but this is really smooth usually i get
kind of stutters and stuff like that in
my older
macbook pros so far no swap at all we do
see more pressure here
and this pressure gauge is designed to
make it simple because right now with
mac os there's so much going
on there's swap there's cash there's
compression
but for this typical workload we're not
really
seeing any difference so far it's fine
so now let's go ahead
and open up photoshop i do have the new
photoshop
beta installed now i am trying to use
arm optimize
applications because after a little bit
most apps will be optimized
and let's go ahead and drag four
different files
into photoshop they'll start loading
them up
so it looks like at this point the eight
gig is starting to fill up we have some
swap being used even though we're not
maxing out our ram yet now i know some
of you guys are worried about swap you
guys are worried about mac os riding to
it
and you want to buy 16 gig just because
of that well i have a news flash for you
my mac pro with 192 gigabytes of ram
i've never seen it over a hundred with
photoshop open video editing pro
programs bunch of chrome tabs but i have
seen it right to swap
it's just how mac os works it's
optimized engineers know what they're
doing
i wouldn't worry about it that much but
what we care about is actual
performance switching between these 42
megapixel images i'm not seeing
any difference so far and let's go ahead
and open up
final cut pro it defaulted to that 8k
project i'll keep that open in the
background and i'll go ahead and open up
the standard
4k project and let's go ahead and hit
play
both of these are playing back this 4k
with film grain
two luts applied at full 4k quality
without any issues and this is how i
typically use my macbook pros when i'm
video editing
sometimes i won't even have photoshop
open if i'm not working on a thumbnail
let's keep that playing back 3.25 gigs
of swap
but interestingly the 16 gigabyte is
compressing
twice as much as our 8 gigabyte model
and before i open more applications and
a lot more tabs i'm going to run the
speedometer test
one more time keep in mind we have
photoshop open
final cut with a couple projects open we
have safari
we have chrome with videos running in
the background
all right well it looks like we have
basically the same results at this
point and now let's go ahead and open up
xcode i have it opened up here for our
standard benchmark
and it is indexing in the background and
then along with that
let's go ahead and open up logic pro
just in case you want to work on some of
your tunes
as you're working with photoshop and
final cut
and what else xcode i went ahead and
enabled
50 tracks here and let's see if we have
any
issues of these systems overloading
now just to remind you guys the previous
intel based macbook pro and macbook air
those can only do under 10 tracks
without anything else
running and looking over here they're
both playing this back
just fine taking a peek into the
activity monitor
the 16 gig finally wrote just one
megabyte to the ssd whereas the 8 gig
rope 4.6
gigabytes the pressure actually went
down now
compared to the 16 which is interesting
and neither of these systems had an
issue getting through
30 seconds here i'm gonna go ahead and
pause this right now
and keep it open i will go back into
chrome
and let's go ahead and open up a bunch
more tabs we have video ads running in
the background
it seems like so far my internet is
getting hit harder than the ram on these
systems
i have 20 chrome tabs open and
it looks like the 16 gig model is
actually stuttering
more so you guys let me know if you guys
are seeing that
now a lot of these websites have
different ads that keep loading and
reloading which is really annoying with
some of these sites
i have apple open tesla open i have
um ign over here with another video
that's playing back and on top of that i
should still have
a youtube video open and playing back
and 1080p
um i don't think my internet will pull
4k right now with everything else
that's happening in the background let's
go back into google drive
it says i'm offline okay my internet's
maxed out i guess
all right i guess it connected now let's
scroll
still pretty dang good look at
everything that's loaded up here yes i
have way too much stuff
in my google drive let's flip through
these tabs
still very nice and quick on the 16
gigabyte model
no issues there at all let's try the 8
gig model
okay well look at that 20 tabs plus i
think
four or five in safari that looks good
let's go ahead and open up our final cut
again lag there for a second the 16
gigabyte model
you guys saw it actually opened up
instantly do photoshop
that was fast slight lag on the eight
gigabyte model
how about logic i'll go ahead and click
these at the same time
slightly faster than the 16 gig how
about xcode
slightly faster once again let's go back
into photoshop okay the same there
probably because we just had to open
back to final cut okay both are the same
and we haven't touched safari for a
while
pretty much the same there let's check
on activity monitor
and this is interesting we have almost
13 gigs used out of 16
and we have four gigs of swap and then a
bunch of compressed now in the 8 gig one
we're using 6.2 with 6.7 gigs of swap so
even though we have 16 gigs here it's
compressing more and it's still
writing ram to the ssd
when we have this much stuff open let's
jump into final cut and let's play back
this file both are playing back
perfectly and my next question is what
about the rendering speeds
in final cut because when you're
exporting it's using a bunch more
processing to create that file now in
vadim's test yesterday without any
background stuff open
it was exactly the same so let's take a
look and while that's happening i'm
going to go ahead and flip through
some of these tabs the 16 gig model is
still
super quick at switching everything is
just showing up very little delay there
at the end
you guys see that we're getting a little
bit of delay it's pretty minimal
now what about the 8 gig model we're
seeing a little bit more delay
so you guys could probably see that
difference there
all right it's speeding up some of these
have a bunch of ads on there
still surprisingly good as we're
rendering 4k video
jumping back into final cut well we're
starting to see a difference in
export times this one's at 58 and this
one's just at 25
26 i'll pull up activity monitor
we actually have six gigs written to the
ssd here
and eight gigs written here but a lot
more pressure
especially when we started exporting all
right the 16 gig one
just finished the same exact three
minutes and five seconds
whereas this one's at just over fifty
percent so it looks like it's going to
take about six minutes now
keep in mind though that we have logic
open
we have xcode open we have photoshop
open
we have four tabs in safari 20
in chrome and with that many of these
auto reload applications i have video
playing in youtube also on ign
and i would never be using them like
this in the real world
i'll go ahead and close xcode and logic
and let's go and export that one more
time
to see even with all those tabs open and
everything else in the background which
i would never
do it will actually get better rendering
times with eight gigs
because i don't know who would run x
code and logic
and photo editing and video editing and
all those tabs
all right and it looks like now we are
much closer
we're at 18 here 17 here so just one
percentage point
off and without logic and xcode it is so
similar here as far as how much is being
written to the ssd
the 8 gig model is just having to
compress more
of that ram which mac os is so good at
so maybe it's
taken away a little bit performance from
the video exporting
the 16 gigabyte finish once again three
minutes in five
seconds and the eight gigabyte one is
almost done
three minutes and 20 seconds so
with eight gigabytes of ram it takes you
about 15 seconds longer
running final cut with photoshop open
with a bunch of high-res
images safari tons of chrome tabs
i honestly was expecting a bigger
difference and this thing is exporting
i think still faster than the 16-inch
macbook pro
with just running final cut let's open
up photoshop again and
wow that was the same speed it was
pretty much instant there
flip through some of these photos still
pretty fast
let me go ahead and open up my
magnifying glass
and let's zoom in here okay no issues
let's zoom out
still nice and smooth let's grab a brush
and let's
just draw on here a lot of times you can
have lag
especially if you're running out of ram
it'll just start glitching up
both are perfectly smooth no issues and
these macbooks have been
great and it looks like this photoshop
for arm the beta version is awesome as
well
and now let's go ahead and open up
lightroom classic and this is an
intel based application it's not
optimized for arm
i typically would close final cut if i'm
doing just photo editing out of
photoshop and lightroom open
in this case we're doing a stress test
so let's keep it open even though i
normally wouldn't
there's both i think the 8 gig one
actually all loaded up faster
these are 42 megapixel images but they
are
raw with a bunch of different effects
added and lightroom is a ram
hog the more ram you can give it the
faster it will perform
so let's go ahead and just click next
and this is where people get frustrated
where they're switching files
and each time i hit next we're loading
up that 42 megapixel raw image
and adding a bunch of different
corrections and changes
to it but i'm shocked by how close
it is when we're switching let's grab an
exposure brush
all right there you guys can see
we are lagging along on the eight gig
but the 16
is perfectly smooth i'm gonna go ahead
and undo
and let's try that again just so you
guys can see the difference we are
getting lag
so there you go you guys see the eight
gig one it's lagging behind
now i'm curious what happens if i close
uh
my video projects in final cut just
because i would never
run final cut video editing and
photoshop and be editing a ton of photos
in lightroom
as you guys could see i am not seeing
any difference so closing
final cut there but keeping all those
tabs and videos open
made a big difference and let's go ahead
and export
50 of these hi-res edited images
to jpeg vadim did see some differences
in export speeds between 8 and 16
and i'm curious about with all those
tabs open the videos playing back
photoshop open what can have a
difference we'll see this time
under a really stressed environment wow
okay so the 16 gig model
it's been a couple minutes our 16 gig
model
is almost complete at about 80 percent
the cpu has been maxed out
whereas our 8 gigabyte model it looks
like to be about 35
complete or so the other weird thing is
that the 16 gigabyte model
is getting loud for the first time i've
never heard that before
whereas the 8 gig one is still silent
and the cpu it hits 100 then it drops
down to
35 now it's at 73 93
almost like it can't work at its full
speed
well it probably makes sense because it
doesn't have enough ram and because of
that
it is staying silent all right our
export is complete and that took
five minutes compared to two minutes and
43
seconds so yes when we have all those
tabs open chrome
safari we have photoshop open we have
lightroom
open uh you can start to see a
difference in
exporting times now keep in mind these
are massive massive files
before i give you guys my conclusion i'm
gonna go ahead and just switch through
some of these tabs
and we'll see if we have any difference
pretty much identical even with
lightroom open
and lightroom once again is not
optimized
let's open safari which we haven't
opened in a long time
pretty much instant and let's open up
this
bam that is very surprising now let's
grab photoshop again
bam there you go that was instant on
that one here it actually gave me the
pop-up first
and let's just just for kicks let's open
up final cut pro we'll have it reopen
that project
and um the timeline as well
we'll have it reopen that project along
with the 4k
bam slightly faster on the 16 gig now
what did we learn from this video well
if you have
a bunch of chrome tabs open and xcode
and logic
yes the 8 gig model will slow down and
hopefully for those of you guys that are
trying to decide
between buying 8 and 16 if you know
you're having
you know four or five professional
applications open
and 20 chrome tabs and two videos open
and
a bunch of websites that have a bunch of
ads in safari
you are not trying to buy the 8 gig
model and now with that said
i have to say with my final verdict i am
just very shocked by how well this 8
gigabyte model performed even though we
saw it slow down
in lightroom which isn't optimized it
took longer to export
in final cut when we had logic and
everything else opened
i used intel based ones with eight gigs
before
and man even for my standard workload
with just
say a couple tabs in safari maybe five
tabs in chrome and final cut open
i could tell that it was lagging
compared to the 16
macbook pro in this case with that
unified memory being so close to the cpu
not separate
and the new operating system and
optimized applications it is doing
so much better and what i would say is
for those of you guys
that want to get an eight gig system you
don't have that much money you're
stretching your
much budget out if you're not going to
be running all those applications open
and take a look at chrome here
we have render renderer render all this
rendering going in chrome
as we were doing this i wouldn't worry
about that the 8 gig model is performing
great keep one or two applications pro
applications open
keep 10 chrome tabs open you want a
video or two
you can do that maybe a couple in safari
and in that case
they perform very similarly now if you
want to go crazy
in that case well get the 16 gig model
now personally
for myself if i'm buying a macbook pro
and i'm buying it for a few years i'm
going to buy a 16 gig model
200 more i think it's worth it you don't
have to worry about it
and if you want to throw a bunch of
stuff open you know you have the extra
ram
now as far as swap or writing to the ssd
some of you guys are really worried
about that don't worry at all apple
knows what they're doing
and if you're worried about writing to
ssd and you know messing up the
longevity
go and check out some longevity
endurance tests
there were tests from 2013 with the
first ssds
that were only rated for about 80
terabytes written and those would work
until about 600
to a thousand nowadays these ssds are
miles better they'll last 20 30 times
longer
than those ones so i would not worry
about having
the mac os right to your ssd even the 16
gigabyte model you can't get away from
it don't buy that 16 gigabyte model and
spend 200
extra just for ssd longevity that makes
no sense so there you guys go my final
thoughts are
the 8 gig model performs like a 16
gigabyte intel
macbook pro and the 16 gigabyte model
performs
more like a 32 gigabyte macbook pro or
maybe even
better than that honestly it performs
extremely well under
all of that it was still doing things
really
fast so if you want the ultimate
performance i guess you have the money
get the 16 gig
that's what i would do personally if
you're not on a tight budget
let me know your thoughts down in the
comment section below on this
you know crazy multitasking stress test
as far as ram did that answer you guys
questions
thank you guys for watching this been
max click that circle above to subscribe
and check out one of those other
great videos right over there and i'll
see you in the next one